he's Joe Thomas the former Cleveland
Brown offensive lineman where are you
right now Joe Joe Thomas is coming back
Joe Thomas coming out of retirement
Wow that is breaking news new story for
the day all right we have a game that we
want apply guess Joe Thomas's weight now
okay okay so you were about 311 is that
what your official weight was in your
last year my last year I played about
305 oh okay
so we already made our picks let's go
around the room Fritzi you said I said
262 okay Paulie to 77 Seton to 9-0 all
right and McLovin to 67 I went with your
jersey number and threw a two in front
of it Joe so I went to seven three Joe
Thomas's official weight to 69 okay
McLovin what did you have to sixty-seven
okay well done yeah you didn't go over I
I went over all right Joe thank you
that's all we needed
good luck so what are you doing at the
Browns you know facility yeah you know
what I'm still rehabbing my elbow injury
from the fall and I'm also trying to
stick around the rest of the spring
through many camp to help some of these
offensive linemen some of the young
tackles that hopefully are gonna be
taking over for me are you retired
retired I'm done okay no there's no
coming back for me trust me the scale
says 269 there's no coming back for that
what did you want the Browns to do last
night and what do you think of what they
did last night I thought they did a good
job
I thought Mayfield was a great ticket
number one I thought rosin was the best
quarterback in his draft but I don't
know anything about quarterback so you
can take that with a grain of salt
I thought Denzel Ward was a great pick
personally at number four I would have
taken Bradley Chubb because I like being
able to combine him with Miles Garrett
was adding a great cornerback the top
back in the draft to a position of need
for us I think was also a great decision
we had you on last year and this is
leading up to the draft and I asked Joe
Thomas the following question and I
would say you want a go defense I think
you need to get a pass rusher I think
you got to be careful reaching for a
quarterback at number one because if
they fail they don't help your team at
all whereas if you pick a defensive
lineman and maybe they don't live up to
the hype you can still find a place to
get them on the field and to have an
impact and we're a team that we need
guys that can come in and I can start
and they can contribute and I think
that's the risk of taking a quarterback
you still feel that way well I think
that was the situation that the Browns
were in last season I think it's a
different situation now because we have
added some of those pieces we did add
miles geared who I think is going to be
a generational pass rusher by the end of
his career so now I think the time was
right for us to add a quarterback at
number one I thought Mayfield was a
great decision I would have picked Josh
Rosen but I think Mayfield was one of
the top probably two guys and I think he
can be a great fit in Cleveland what
advice would you give Baker Mayfield um
the only advice I would give him is uh
keep your head down as a rookie keep
your mouth shut
your eyes open try to learn as much as
you possibly can and don't and and it's
important that he wants the plate but
don't be so eager to play that you
forget like your most important job or
right when you get there is learn the
offense be a good teammate do what you
can to help your team win
are there any comparisons with Manziel
well certainly there's gonna be a lot of
comparisons just because of they both
played in the big 12 that both Texas
guys they're shorter quarterbacks that
can run but I think the big difference
from Johnny to Baker based on what they
did in college is Baker's ability to
make plays within the pocket go through
his progressions through his reads
throwing on time on the money that was
something that Johnny didn't do a lot of
in college Johnny was more of make plays
outside of the pocket make plays
aren't exactly written up they're more
of like the written up in the dirt type
plays but I think Baker transitions his
game a little bit better towards what
the NFL game requires best defensive
lineman you ever faced was who pass
rusher was Dwight Freeney I think the
best overall guys were DeMarcus Ware and
trail Suggs who did you need help with
did you ever ask for help my pride was
too much at what I got it I was did you
did you ever talk to these guys you're
not a talker right no no I the talking
that I did was basically to try to
sweeten them up you know I would ask him
how their family was you know talk to
him about nursery rhyme things to make
him docile you know I learned early on
that you don't want to poke the sleeping
bear you know if drugs is out there and
he's taking a nap during the game don't
get him fired up by trash-talking him
did you ever apologize to a quarterback
after a sink actually yes I did it was
my rookie year it wasn't even in the
regular season it was in the Pro Bowl I
was going against Julius Peppers and he
beat me inside and sacked Peyton Manning
who is our quarterback like in the first
quarter and I went gates down to help
Peyton up and he just gave me this look
like are you kidding me you got me
sacked in the promo you idiot and at
that point I said sorry Peyton I never
got the acknowledgment of the apology so
maybe I'll have to confront them down
the line there yeah I'm so sorry mr.
Manning so sorry
hey is there any chance you're doing
Monday Night Football for ESPN oh you
never know I was one of the maybe ten
guys or so that auditions and I know
they're starting to go through the
process of kind of whittling down the
prospects I think maybe they have one
guy or they're just finishing their
auditions so I'm sure we'll be hearing
something probably within the next month
good to talk to you Joe have fun and
we'll stay in touch thank you
break them that's uh Joe Thomas former
Browns offensive lineman hall-of-famer
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]